[Music]
in baby factory news hold a women news
balls
that's my balls yep submitted by Susan
from Thailand
although Susan I always wanted to go to
Thailand that's probably your last name
you a Japanese man one sole custody of
13 children he had through surrogate
mothers what oh so he just kept coming
in a cup and then they were popping out
kids and if he took them all what is he
doing with that army of children yeah
yeah pretty much
Joe that's you that's you could be doing
that yeah yeah but I actually want to
[ __ ] that's a waste yeah like are you
gonna pop out all these kids and then
it's like well he could've still I mean
just cuz they were surrogate doesn't
mean no that's like missing out on the
best part that's like getting fat
without even eating whoa the best the
best part of it Joe is the child duh the
gift of life I love children
now with the [ __ ] I love the children
no that's like the when you run and then
if you're a first place and then you hit
the finish line the finish line is the
children but the challenge is the sex in
the relationship can you imagine doing
with 13 baby mamas oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I could barely deal with
one and if I'm Mormon I can why what
happens now that you're Mormon but
there's like you know how to obey the
man but a good woman legit though I
think like isn't that like the [ __ ] like
the man is the thing of the household
what he says goes in that [ __ ] I don't
know but I should dunno where the world
[ __ ] really watch the dog to manage yeah
dad it's a full-time job because like
not only do they have to work he's most
good like I guess what do you call Poli
it says they do Sister Wives yeah yeah
but they all want his attention so so he
has to give affection to all of them
right so he created like a day that
everyone gets and then schedules like at
night
so those this documentary on how he
lives and it's like whoa dude that's a
lot of work thank you hola check it out
I just have to put it this way
all right 13 females on their period I'm
done exactly I think it's easier for one
wound a cycle it's easier for one woman
to deal with ten guys or thirteen guys
yeah one man to deal with oh yeah a
hundred percent technically yeah
thirteen women
it's like forty-six because women at
multiple personnel yeah because that one
wife all she has to do is just pretty
much give five minutes to every guy [ __ ]
them and then they're happy as hell yeah
does that mean that that guy would have
to let's say that he has like eight
wives so when he's splitting that
between the he has to [ __ ] all of them
okay so I think wait funny story
I'm very recently was seeing a guy that
I actually met like on tendon this is
really funny we were seeing each other
for a month and one day he invites me to
his apartment and about 30 minutes later
this woman named Mitch she came over and
found out that he had also been seeing
her too but he wanted us to be friends
with each other oh yeah we both left and
then a month later she ended up dating
him but like it was just funny that he
was raised Mormon and like 20 years
later he's still trying to reenact the
Sister Wives because that's how he was
raised and he actually thinks that they
should all be friends so like they think
of it as all of the women are friends
with each other and like everything's
chill what a wonderful system my
question is do you think Mormons all the
future together
Oh Jorgie yeah if they're Sister Wives
right like yeah like is it like a porno
we're one sucking the dick and the other
ones licking the balls like that's my
question I sure hope so
oh so they're all servicing him yeah I
feel like it's give and take you know
what I mean
there is a series fun what it looks like
yeah I've seen it I've seen it it's a
pornhub original it's like it's like I
can't I don't I don't know what it's
called I just seen it before like when I
was we were going through watching weird
porn or something one day and like
there's Mormon porn this is the one guy
yes you're fine so much that's so much
work I'm just curious if that's how it
plays out so this guy here he's an heir
of a wealthy Japanese businessman all
duty while the other one has she's
moving on in the stories man questions
area okay I'm listening
booty everybody should love beauty
that's Joe you've been right into this
bucket piece of trash he's a 28 year old
baby factory dad his name is Jill he
said he's an error right he's an heir to
wealthy but Japanese business he's
awesome happening so he's believed to
have fathered at least at least
seventeen children all conceived through
surrogacy and so this whole scandal
began in 2014 while entire thora teas
stormed his bangkok apartment and that's
where they found nine surrogate babies
each accompanied by a nanny living in
unfurnished rooms by play pans and baby
bottles what a [ __ ] is he doing where's
the moms at I'm not sure oh they're all
surrogate so they're not involved with
the baby
oh he just I'm so done he's employing
these ladies to just pop out his kid why
and he's ping or he has even like the
dizzies he want like an error for his
fortune might he like the key I think
he's trying to raise an army that's kind
of more so let me tell you this guy's so
lucky he paid them each between nine
thousand three hundred dollars and
twelve thousand five hundred dollars
each
that's how much it goes for to make
these kids right yeah and so he was
going to this one particular clinic
named new life clinic and the woman the
founder of that clinic she ended up
letting Interpol know that there's
something suspicious going on with this
guy because this guy said that he wanted
to have 10 to 15 babies a year what the
and every time he got is there you're
pregnant
immediately she wanted more women to get
pregnant like back to back to back to
back he's trying to be like Genghis Khan
so he told her the founder that he
wanted to run an election and win by
using his big family for the voting
that's ridiculous
yeah how can you have so much money
would be so dumb I know like at the most
that's like 8,000 votes yes nothing like
by a calculator like that what see
that's what happens when you're just an
area you just have money you don't have
to have critical thinking money just
comes out to the skyline I literally met
people who are so [ __ ] rich they do
not live in this world you know what I
mean just how they like view just buying
things and like just having things it's
way different than us
it's like they'll walk into a store like
for me when I look at a menu I look at
the number yeah I go oh today I can have
this today you know what I mean for them
it's just this this is that whatever oh
do you want some of this yeah well let's
just order the whole menu and just leave
it there just walk out like I've
literally had meals with people like
this and it's like the bills like a
grand and they just know do you want to
try some great we'll just order it just
have a pie just leave it there like what
the [ __ ] you know like it's just
different world different my state they
don't know [ __ ] yeah well the reason why
he was awarded full custody out of he's
ballin exactly he proved he has produced
enough evidence to show that he can
properly take care of all
kid legit though if I had the like
financial freedom I probably would have
liked one of my having four kids yeah
cuz he's saying they came up in a big
family himself and so he wanted to have
many children and for them all to grow
together
there's no mommy that's the same they
need love I'll be sick and [ __ ] like you
mom messes with them use the photo of
the do Oh God and if my dad look like
that I'd be so the surrogate mom this is
a different one where's the mom and then
here's like some like press conference
type of thing my god those babies are
cute as really kid
yeah look at this he [ __ ] this all up
because first off I hope he screamed the
surrogate mothers or if I would get them
yeah craziest high fighters and in the
tie scientists and like the best minds
of Thailand I don't know why he just
chose Thailand I mean did it he could
have done this like in Europe and all
probably more inexpensive cuz out here I
think it goes for like 30 but you got
Billy in there like or whatever like
he's so Asian that's true he's like [ __ ]
away with it over there yeah but he's
Japanese
so I don't know you know is he that
cheap uh so I don't know well so cuz I
would this is what I would have done I
would have gone to Africa South America
I would have gone all over the world and
you would have had some beautiful babies
yep
and I would choose different like ones
for different reasons because I'm
creating the x-men of my genes it's
gonna be like the strongest lady that's
gonna be like the dictator of South
America and then I'm gonna have like the
most intelligent like person that's
gonna figure out how to cure cancer and
[ __ ] no Nobel Peace Prizes and they're
just gonna be like my Illuminati but
it's gonna be my genes imagine there was
some sort of algorithm or something
where you can see how your kid would
come out if you make think your genes
with other people genes they're close
yeah
certain things that you could already
pick you can't let sue pick your jeans
and jail that's [ __ ] data contributed
I just think like you know yeah like
Gattaca all I would love to pick some
[ __ ] jeans is [ __ ] ya need to go yeah
cuz I got a lot of weakness in my
bloodline the line of jugglers and
fairies that's really about it man
both my ankles have fractured tore my
MCL already what else oh I have an
inguinal hernia what else do I have
oh I had a I had a slipped disc in my
back
two at two places that's cuz you like
play it crazy sports and stuff yeah but
that even though there's other people
who play sports you must train like 12
hours a day let me tell you my MLB I
wake up and I eat then we die and then
home yeah but [ __ ] [ __ ] you sighs
there's something in my gene this is
brittle bones I just need to take that
[ __ ] up in the glass man yeah oh and
also I was basically blind before LASIK
so yeah yeah I am a miracle you know
what though it's funny cuz I'll probably
try to work out something happens to
have you noticed slip disc some [ __ ] and
then I thought I have a Negrito hernia
you call it too hard you gotta take baby
steps I saw you at maybe you do that on
purpose so you know I do not want to
have a [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks but I don't
really soft this time I just found I got
it from a previous thing and I
apparently got but you work out like
you're trying to raise the pyramids of
Egypt take some take some baby steps
you just started today man he's trying
to raise the pyramids what does that
like not eating anything at all but
working out bigger no you know like he's
pulling one of those big bricks up the
freakin glass very excessive David
because my mind is already bodybuilder
but the rest hasn't caught up yet see
your mind is what you watch on Netflix
yeah exactly everything I see on TV is
right here dude I'm going into a
professional boxing match tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]